I I just had to ask this one question
because you've done so many so many
films that everybody I imagine any time
you get stopped it's always a different
film because there's so many that are
just not just great maybe just have such
a great impact on humanity overall like
whether it was you know a deeper thing
or a lighter thing there any way or any
sort but I I'm curious like what your
favorite movie to do was I know that's
probably got to be a hard cuz people ask
me questions but funny enough everybody
always thinks I love The Bodyguard that
is like one of my favorite movies of all
time but that's not my favorite of yours
and this says something about me that my
favorite I think it's called mr. Brooks
and you're a serial serial killer okay I
love that one because it was so out of
pocket and I thought it the story was
amazing how was interesting at the end
and I it was just something that was
unpredictable for me when I watched it
but I was curious what's one of yours
like what's one that sticks out but like
if it's on you like keep on and not turn
off well I don't do that I don't fall in
love with myself on the screen like ears
like I mean like years of watching
sometime sometimes the kids will walk in
and that goes that that's you and and
and it's like no they won't let me turn
it off for a second and eventually I
kind of have to walk out of the room but
what I know in my heart is that when you
make a movie there's a chance for it to
live forever and it looks forever if
it's fresh air if it if it if a
challenge is you if it makes you laugh
if it makes you cry if it surprises you
movies have all those those things going
for it but what they have is they also
have the ability to do something that
you'll never ever forget it's just hard
movies aren't easy to so it's hard to
make a great one I agree subscribe to my
channel subscribe to my channel
subscribe to my channel subscribe to my
channel please don't make me keep going